pues es el momento para hablar de
economía aquí en France 24 contamos para
ello con nuestra compañera Daniela
hablandon Daniela Buenos días Hola
Buenos días Rodrigo y venimos hablando
tanto hoy como de otros días durante las
últimas semanas de visitas de líderes
europeos a China son visitas que no son
solo políticas sino más bien económicas
también económicas de Rodrigo Emmanuel
macron viajó con una delegación
empresarial de medio centenar de
personas incluidos los altos ejecutivos
de airbus que a propósito firmó un
acuerdo para vender aviones a China y
para montar una segunda planta de
ensamblaje también otros como el gigante
de lujo Louis Vuitton o el productor de
energía nuclear edf las relaciones
económicas de Europa con china se han
deteriorado en los últimos años y la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
Legend ha sido bastante crítica por
ejemplo con los incentivos a la
industria que hacen que las empresas
prefieran instalarse en China y ha dicho
que hay que eliminar el riesgo de Los
lazos con Belinda bueno hablas de este
deterioro de relaciones Daniela Pero en
qué punto Cómo están estas relaciones
comerciales Pues mira ahora son bastante
dependientes los europeos de china hoy
por ejemplo este país le vende al bloque
400 mil millones de euros más de lo que
le compra al año y suple el 20% de sus
importaciones mientras que la proporción
de lo que le exporta es muchísimo menor
hay sectores también es más estratégicos
que otros el 15% de los automóviles que
exporta la Unión Europea la mayoría
proviene de Alemania pues va al país
asiático y casi todo el suministro de
tierras raras de litio o de Magnesio
todo esto es utilizado para productos
que van desde baterías hasta centrales
eólicas es chino y de China también
llegan los paneles solares que usan los
europeos parece Claro que esta nueva
economía verde va a llevar china a la
delantera desde
y nos vamos a Venezuela porque nuevos
malos datos de la inflación en el país
pues según el observatorio venezolano de
finanzas que es una entidad
independiente la inflación interanual en
marzo fue del 501% y solamente en el mes
los precios subieron 4,2 por ciento es
verdad que estos 16 puntos porcentuales
menos que en febrero cuando habían
subido 20,2% interanual Venezuela fue
uno de los 10 países que participaron
ayer miércoles en una Cumbre virtual
Como cada por el mandatario mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador para buscar
soluciones a la alta inflación de la
región y de la que hay que decirlo
también no hubo ningún anuncio Más allá
de que se van a volver a reunir El seis
y siete de mayo esta vez de manera
presencial Bueno pues de Venezuela nos
vamos hasta Argentina que lanzado
medidas para incentivar las
exportaciones agropecuarias de que se
trata Daniela Pues el Ministerio de
economía dio a conocer un nuevo tipo de
cambio fijo de 300 pesos argentinos
superior al mayorista de 210 pesos que
va a regir para el sector productor de
soya y sus derivados entre el 8 de abril
y el 31 de mayo próximos ya el país
había puesto en marcha el año pasado en
dos ocasiones un tipo de cambio
diferencial para exportaciones de soya a
un valor más conveniente que este tipo
de cambio oficial sin embargo ahora el
gobierno cree que necesita una nueva
actualización dado el impacto que ha
tenido la sequía sobre los productores
escuchemos medidas que de alguna manera
lo que pretenden es
fortalecer por un lado al sector
agroexportador argentino y con ese
fortalecimiento del sector
agroexportador argentino fortalecer
nuestras reservas y nuestra moneda tan
importante en momentos de incertidumbre
y volatilidad a nivel global y a nivel
local bueno cambiamos de región estamos
en medio del ramadán y hay un país que
con muchos con mucha población musulmana
que tiene la inflación de alimentos más
alta del mundo cuál se trata pues
Rodrigo hablamos del Líbano que
atraviesa una de las depresiones más
profundas de la historia moderna y su
inflación alimentaria interanual alcanza
el 139% y no hay ninguna otra nación Que
lo supere según el Banco Mundial Esto
hace de este año especialmente atípico
para los libaneses en este ramadán como
usted lo dice un mes sagrado que
generalmente se considera un momento de
celebración con grandes comidas al
atardecer sin embargo la crisis
financiera les está robando al uso del
líbaneses esta tradición
Esta es la primera vez en la historia de
nuestras vidas que la gente compra
frutas y verduras por unidad todos
compraban tres cuatro o cinco kilos
ahora todos compran por pieza la
situación es mala para todos
ahora la gente compra la cabeza del
pescado antes solíamos botarla no se
vendía pero ahora se usan cabezas de
pescado para sopas